chuck
hey yeah i got another explainer video
except i'm not the one that's going to
be doing the explaining oh thank
god i didn't know it was so
troublesome for you to have to sit
through my 10 to 15 minute
lectures no you know i i i love our
explainers they
they are fascinating and they are fun
and okay
and this just this just mixes it up a
little bit more what are you
well let you know i'm not the only
explainer out there just letting you
know but you are the explainer in teeth
[Laughter]
all right i will take that title thank
you very much so
today we're going to talk about
osiris-rex
is a is uh i bet it's an acronym uh but
we're going to find out
what it is and what it's trying to do uh
in fact i think i know what it's trying
to do you know what's going to do chuck
it's going to go to an asteroid
right fine we've done that before
they're going to collect a sample fine
we've done that before
that but then it's going to bring it
back uh-oh wait a minute
now wait do we well so you said asteroid
right
i was going to say if if it was a comet
then we could wait for it to come back
well okay well some asteroids are on
their way straight towards us as well
that's true that is true i don't like to
think about them though
let me bring in our special expert guest
lucy lim
lucy welcome to star talk oh
happy to be here thank you so much
excellent your assistant project
scientist for osiris
rex research scientist at nasa's goddard
uh solar system exploration division
and this is nasa goddard in in maryland
there's another nasa goddard in new york
city
that involves planetary atmospheres but
the larger
nasa goddard space flight center is in
greenbelt maryland
and you formally studied asteroids
on their near earth asteroid rendezvous
mission the near
mission so you've been at this for a
while that's right ever since i was
writing my thesis as a as a grad student
as as a young graduate student
so what so so tell me where are you
going and what do you bring him back
and and should we should you be allowed
to do this
okay so our mission there's irish tracks
mission
um is it an acronym was it it is an
acronym yes
origins spectral interpretation resource
identification security regolith
explorer i think you need a few more
letters there
lucy just
okay you're really pushing that one wow
it was our mission leadership was very
proud of themselves and they realized
they could make that spell like egyptian
mythology
and dinosaurs like and mash them
together
okay i am not ever gonna re-recite what
those letters mean
okay just so you know okay so um
so tell me we we've actually talked
about asteroids and
sample returns before so what what is
going to happen on this mission and why
should we all pay attention
yes well first and fore foremost this is
a sample return mission
so it's nasa's most um ambitious sample
return mission since apollo
um so a lot of people may not be aware
that nasa's had a couple of other sample
return missions there was the
stardust mission and the genesis mission
um which both flew kind of in the early
2000s
um so it's not so those were those were
samples from comets
start this was a sample from a comet yes
um and genesis was a solar wind mission
solar wind okay yes that's right but
they didn't have to go down to the
surface
of anything and pick the samples up so
that's why
that's what makes this irish rex a
little more complicated than those two
missions
um so all they had to do was fly through
the the the debris trail and just scoop
it up and bring it back
absolutely exactly right okay so that's
nothing compared to what you're doing
exactly
you guys are you guys are landing on an
asteroid
getting stuff and cut so where does
bruce willis fit into all of this
that's right well we're not yeah we we
have we have a
kind of a scaled down um it's not quite
a drill
it's got but it's got air jets to get
into the surface instead of
instead of like you know the whole oil
rig type thing
now i i can kind of understand why we
might get a sample from a comet
because it's it's got this organic
material it might have water
it might it's just they seem kind of
more interesting to me in my naive
thinking than an asteroid so
what's what are you getting on this
asteroid that that you're not getting
anywhere else
yeah well that's that does go to why we
picked this exact asteroid
um so asteroids space rocks are not the
same all
all the same as each other um so when
when you look at our our meteorites the
space rocks that come come
come to us for free exactly which is
totally awesome
we love them um you know they
they come in several different types
some of them are igneous rocks some of
them are
obviously never part of a melt um so
igneous would be
it was in a volcano and was molten and
then hardened
yeah a volcano or or an underground
magma chamber either one
wait wait wait what's the difference
between lava and magma
oh magma is underground lava is after
it's erupted on top
so you're changing the name of it just
for because of where it is um
pretty much yeah and there's also
magma lavre and tephra like from from
bottom to top right like so tephra as if
it sprays out into the you know
um and gets airborne wow so airborne
lava rather than slowing lava is tephra
right
yeah which by the way is the you never
ever
want to meet tephra no that's true that
is correct
you want to wait for that stuff to fall
back down to the ground
don't invite tephra to the party you
don't want to stand in the
in in the bleachers with the mitt trying
to catch
the world trying to catch food so thank
you for this
for this bit of vocabulary lesson i
guess i think
initially i thought it was weird but
it's not that weird when um
a meteor is a rock falling through the
atmosphere and when it falls on the
ground it's a meteorite
right so i shouldn't complain about this
yeah it's geology man yeah okay
all right so what do you so what are you
after yeah so
okay so out of out of um
the meteorites that are that did not you
know that
did not come out of a melt at any at any
point and we we know that because they
have stuff in them that like
you know if it had melted it would have
like chemically reacted or gotten mixed
together or separated apart like
there are things that you find together
in these meteorites that
that tell you that it's it's definitely
not an igneous rock
so i guess what you're you're suggesting
that whatever you bring back
will be different from all other
meteorites on earth
um it will certainly be different from
what from the majority
but about okay so when a meteorite falls
it falls to earth
about four or five percent of the time
you get something
that we that that we call carbonaceous
that like there's carbon and organic
compounds and stuff in it
um and so from life's point of view it's
interesting chemistry
very interesting yeah and then a couple
percent of the time you get something
that also has hydration in it
um so there's even minerals that have
water in their structure
and more in general a greater variety
and complexity of organic
molecules so so you're using hydration
in exactly the way cosmetic
people use the word hydration okay
right getting water in you in you in you
okay just that's right they're incor you
wouldn't you know it wouldn't look like
it was wet if you
looked at you know if you looked at one
of these meteorites it would look like
an or normal rock and
um and but the water molecules are
embedded within
the structure that's what you're saying
correct and you see that on earth rocks
all the time like we have tons of rocks
any
you know anything that's a clay or if
you
if you're familiar with mica or biotite
minerals like some of the they're pretty
easy
sometimes people like to do crafts and
stuff with them or opal
like all of those things have water
molecules like inside the rock but that
doesn't mean that you you could quench
your thirst with one of them
yeah just squeeze squeeze the rock and
believe me i've
tried many times drinking a glass of
pebbles
[Laughter]
okay so now so you land down so so here
we are
on earth a moving platform headed for an
asteroid which is itself moving
then it doesn't just land right does do
you have an orbiter and then that
deploys
a lander yeah so we're our strategy we
call it
touch and go so we're only going to make
contact with the asteroid for five
seconds
wow so we're great yeah so
land or so um proximity operations
around an asteroid
um are a little bit different or or
coming down a touch and asteroid is a
little
it's a little bit different from coming
down to touch something really big like
the moon
or the earth or mars you know we you may
have heard seven minutes of terror
coming you know coming screaming down
through the martian atmosphere
um to get the rover through the
atmosphere right
yeah exactly because mars is a big
planet with a you know enough gravity
that you you come
that you know you can't come in slowly
you have to come in at
you know by the time you get you get
there you've you've had a lot of
acceleration
you have to lose all that velocity
whereas
um you can match velocities with an
asteroid
and then still and the gravity is so low
you can still come in slowly
oh so you just sort of dip down and kiss
it
exactly you are literally gonna tap that
asteroid
um and then we're going to blow it or
raspberry
yeah oh to to dust it up we are
okay let me ask you this wait wait wait
so what you're going to dust up and then
you're going to get that dust
yes oh that's really brilliant but
it's a little scary because now here's
what i'm thinking from what i understand
bennu is a neo and it is also
inside of that little frame or the
parameter
where it under some circumstance could
possibly hit
earth um you guys kind of bumping into
this cadet
i'm just saying could you perhaps change
the trajectory in any way that you might
so yeah let's ask that because chuck
used the the abbreviation neo near earth
object
uh so bennu is a near-earth asteroid is
that right
it absolutely is okay so oh chuck it
absolutely is
all right now you're gonna kiss it could
you kiss it and touch it and push it in
the wrong orbit yeah
we we did a lot of math because he so
the the team did a lot of math to make
sure that wasn't going to happen
okay how confident are they i was gonna
say
pretty darn
[Laughter]
yes okay all right so wait so now
you collect it and then you tell it to
come back and how do we get it
back on earth what how did how does is
it in the pacific
do you how do you recollect it you have
a net
um that would be pretty awesome if we
could catch it in a net from a
helicopter or something like that
um but no it's going to come down in
utah um the utah
test and training range i think it's
called it's like a missile range
damn i love you guys you just you know
let's go to an asteroid
pick up you know blow it a raspberry
pick up some sample and then have it
come back and land in utah
that's just that's amazing that's just
that's a beautiful thing and utah's low
population density so low risk of
smacking somebody else
well the atlantic ellipse doesn't have
the entire state of utah in it so
they found some place but that nobody
lived because it's a missile range
um and and they made sure that they so
it's gonna it's the oh donate told
that chuck it might trigger a missile
launch yeah exactly
all right um so
uh so all right so then then all of you
you folks who who care deeply about this
mission you
rush to the capsule and you you parse
out
the molecules of of asteroid dust and
you take it back to your lab
yeah it's going to johnson space center
first for um cataloging
and um yeah and and preliminary analysis
and what about safety
um safety of it from us or the other way
around
i'm worried that you took a moment there
because you didn't immediately say oh
yeah of course we're safe
yes both of these topics
asteroid bugs coming to there's a whole
movie called the andromeda story that's
true
all right that is the whole about that
so what is there any precautions that
nasa is taking or you are taking before
we sort of bring this thing into our
environment or your lab
yeah so all of this material will have
been from the top few centimeters of the
surface of this
this asteroid um and what that means so
is that it's been i know i'm i'm getting
air don't worry we're getting there okay
space is full of radiation cosmic rays
you know energetic particles from
distance supernovae
stuff that is not good for life right um
so if you're in the
you know if you're in the top few
centimeters in the asteroid surface all
that radiation is going to penetrate
and get to you so if if you know you you
would have to be
you know it's it's going to be dead if
it's
you know if it's exposed to that
environment for so what you're really
saying is that
you're counting on the sun doing your
job for you
you're you're sterilization
but wait wait but wait and we've got to
actually bring this to a close
but the a question often
when you blow a raspberry the part of
that is so you have access to
layers that are not exactly on the
surface that might be a little more
pristine so often we
seek layers that have not
been assaulted by
by the sun and and high-energy radiation
so
you're going to be content with just the
surface layer that has
been subjected to this kind of high
radiation assault
we are i mean it's um we do expect to
find like a variety of
you know what we call space weathering
which is the effect yeah exposure to
space and space radio
radiation um and you know space
weathering is a process that's
scientifically interesting as
as well but there there should be plenty
of you know whatever organic compounds
are there
does doing this puts you in a position
where let's
for the next time that you can go even
further
is that part of the mission as well i
think it really is especially when we
look at the interaction
of the spacecraft with the surface
because there are a lot of unknowns
unknown unknowns there right now like
you know how how strong is the surface
we have no idea
you know how how big a hole are the jets
going to make in the surface how many
you know how where are the boulders
like how far are those boulders going to
fly and you taking pictures the whole
way so we can watch this happen
we are they won't be down linked until
probably until the following day for
until after they confirm
that the aliens have that's right
that's what we're going for i know you
nasa people
[Laughter]
but guys we gotta uh call it quits there
uh so listen lucy good luck
sometimes you need a little bit of that
too and thanks for being on stage all
right thank you so much it was
excellent chuck always good to have you
man such a pleasure
yeah start talking cleaner video
asteroid sample return i'm neil degrasse
tyson
keep looking
[Music]
you